I think one of the best ways to get the attention of your boss is to become undeniably innovative.
To become the go-to person in the office that people look for, for the next idea or inspiration.
An easy way to become that person...
...is to simply include idea generation and innovation in your daily, weekly, and annual plan.
If you commit to increasing your innovation skills and making idea generation part of your job,...
...you will get noticed by the people that you work with.
Another great way to become an innovation superstar is to aggressively support the people around you...
...and practice behaviors that allow those that you lead to become their best selves.
One of the fundamental rules of improvisation is to make everyone else on stage look better than yourself,...
...to serve the group first and yourself second.
This practice of selfless service is contagious...
...and it will immediately enhance the innovative culture in which you work.
And in the long run, it will always serve you as much as the people that you serve.